- Welcome back to another
installment of
"Mike and Van: The Ascension."
We're here to give you
insider information
about Hollywood
and its workings,
as well as us chronicling
the time that we have spent
as writers on "Key & Peele."
We're just gonna
take you deeper
and delve you deeper
into the creative process
of how we're making
this show better,
because, you know,
frankly, it was okay.
It was a good show.
We're trying to make it
a better show.
We're trying to help
Key and Peele with it.
- You got animals,
pigs, horses, mice.
Then you got the eagle.
And what the eagle does is,
they fly over top.
They get to see
everything below them.
- They looking
at the entire picture.
They're looking
at the whole farm.
- That's where we are.
- That's what we doing.
We straight up talking
about some E-I-E-I-O.
- Dick eagles.
- We are dick eagles.
We're "deagles,"
if you will.
What we trying to do
is run down there
and just like pick up dicks
and eat them out the water,
like salmon.
- [screeching]
- So we gonna show you
a clip really soon
where Mike is having
a conversation.
- I don't know
if I can set this up.
I had had some thoughts
about some of the prosthesis
for the--that's makeup effects.
- Mustaches and beards
and whatnot.
- So I wanted
to share them.
See what you think.
- Hey.
- What's up, Keegan?
- What's it, again?
Tell me your name.
- Mike.
- Mike, that's right.
- Sorry about that.
What can I do you for?
- I got a couple notes.
- Okay, yeah, yeah, come in.
- You should do
a pube beard.
- A what?
- Yo, you, you.
- Are you talking to me
or to Scott?
- No, I'm talking to him, Scott.
You should do
a pubes beard.
Just pubes.
That's...
- Just keep doing
what you're doing.
Just keep doing it.
- I was looking at the script,
though, with Vandaveon.
- Yep.
- It's good.
- Mm-hmm.
- Like, it's funny,
but it could be
a little bit better, though.
- Mike, I really--
buddy, we're not--I...
A pube beard would
probably be very funny
in a lot of instances,
but I'm playing...
- [snickering]
Yeah, no, go on, go on.
- I'm just saying,
if I had a pube beard,
I wouldn't wear it
necessarily for this character.
It's just a surgeon.
He's just a surgeon.
- Just like--can I finish?
Like, some way that y'all could
just make it funnier, though.
- Here's something
that I'm impressed
about this video
in particular,
Mike, is your persistence,
and how you continue to go,
"Hey, I'm--you know,
I have an agenda.
"I want to talk
about these pube beards.
"People should be shaving hair
off their balls
"and putting them
on niggas' faces.
It's important."
- Just being clear
of our vision.
- Mm-hmm, that's important.
And then I think
Key was getting that,
and he was accepting and hearing
the vision that he had in mind.
So you gonna see right now,
in this sketch,
that it is sans pube beard,
a staple of definitely
our style of comedy.
So, by all means, please,
watch this...selection.
- You must be Liam.
- Hey, there, buddy,
how are you feeling?
- I'm feeling...fine,
Dr. Gupta, just fine.
- So now, straight up,
like, as an exercise,
something I would encourage
people to do is, now, like,
in your mind, re-watch
that scene for yourself,
and imagine them
having pube beards on,
especially that
creepy-ass little boy.
Here we're gonna show you
a picture right now
of what that
would look like.
You see?
[laughter]
That's my shit!
- I told these niggas.
- [laughing]
- Told you that was funny.
Told you that.
- He was right
all along, man.
But listen.
We appreciate you
doing the exercise
so that you can understand more
about the nuances
and the subtleties of what
Mike and I will be bringing
to any particular
"Key & Peele" scene.
- Check it out.
- Hey, what's up?
- Hey.
You still haven't really
given me a clear answer
as to what the camera is for.